umd is not even the craziest university
around today
for that you you can't look to the state
universities you have to look
to the wonderful lofty ivy league
where the craziness has somehow
surpassed just about every other
university in the country
cornell university has gone even woker
than the trigger warnings and taking
offensive books off the syllabus cornell
university
wants its students to get a flu
vaccination not the wu flu but the
regular flu
and i everyone's so crazy about public
public health these days that they're
they want all their students to get a
flu
shot however they are going to exempt
certain students from the flu
vaccination
if those students are black
no i'm not making this up if you're a
white
student at cornell and you're on campus
and you're residing there you need to
get the flu vaccine
if you are a black student you don't
need to get the flu vaccine
and so this raises some problems because
i don't get the flu shot and i don't
know that i've ever gotten a flu shot
and i don't intend to this year either
but because i'm a young healthy person
and so my risk is low i guess there's
there is a risk you know there's a risk
to it but
i'm willing to take that risk
there are two there's a contradiction
here right if you believe
that the vaccines are really really
really really good for you
and the flu shot is really really really
good for you
and you say only the white people need
to get it who cares if the black people
get it you sound kind of
racist right right but now but
then if you're saying that white people
have to get the vaccine
and black people don't have to get the
vaccine because the
because these sorts of vaccines and
public health measures
have been really horrible and terrible
to black people over the years
then you're saying that the vaccines
maybe aren't so great you're
undercutting your argument on the facts
either you have to undercut your
argument on race or you have to undercut
your argument
on the vaccines cornell though in the
lofty ivy league
they they don't understand that very
simple issue
historical injustices and current events
will allow black students to avoid
getting the flu shot
and and they're they're referring not
just by the way to
you know scientific experiments that
were undertaken on black people
in various places in the past they're
referring to
the blm argument they're referring to
police brutality you know or the
killing of whoever's you know the the
idea that there's a
scourge and an epidemic of racist cops
killing innocent black men all around
the country
which obviously is not happening but
they're referring to that what does that
have to do with the flu shot
it shows you that the just
trust the science people don't
understand anything about politics
the word science when it is invoked in a
political context
does not refer to the scientific method
of material inquiry or
science in its broader sense knowledge
it's referring specifically to political
knowledge political agendas and i know
that there are some
conservatives i'm not i'm not even
talking about the leftists here
who are totally bought into the
scientific agenda and have been for 150
years
because they view their political agenda
as science itself
so it's illegitimate to dispute it or to
push against it
right the science of politics the
science of history so i'm just talking
to the conservatives there are some
conservatives who say look i don't want
these political battles
over the masks or vaccines or whatever
you know
they they're a little more open to the
masks or these kind of public health
measures they're more willing to listen
to fauci
say look i just i just want to follow
the science i don't want the science to
be
clouded by politics that
is not possible it's not possible
public health refers to science in part
and it refers to politics
the word public is synonymous with
political
they they refer to the exact same thing
when we're talking about public health
we're talking about politics
and all of science
the most hard-nosed scientist who says i
just follow the empirical facts on the
ground
even he will be forced to acquiesce to
politically correct standards
you can't escape no society and no
segment of society can escape
that society's standards and i don't
care how materialist and
and scientific you want to pretend that
you are they won't escape it either
you